[Música]
salud en directo américa de france al 24
y me acompaña en el estudio marina
sardina marina bienvenida buena mañana
de lunes vamos a hablar de la viruela
del mono la monkeypox porque la mitad de
los positivos en todo el mundo se han
reportado en nuestro continente en el
continente americano además eeuu tiene
mayor número de casos con más de 14.500
positivos pero en américa latina' el
nuevo brote está experimentando una alta
velocidad marina así de raúl buenos días
si efectivamente en américa latina' del
brote sigue avanzando tenemos a brasil
en primer lugar con más de 3400 casos
positivos por viruela química le siguen
también perú que es el país con más
casos registrados por cada millón de
habitantes o méjico en tercer lugar que
tiene también una alta tasa de
positividad y donde los activistas se
están criticando al gobierno por su
inactividad
para paliar este brote para hablar de
esto nos acompaña el doctor carlos pérez
que es infectólogo de la universidad
nacional de colombia buenos días doctor
quería preguntarles eeuu tiene en la
región el mayor número de contagios pero
también brasil o perú están con una alta
tasa de positividad cuéntanos un poco
cómo es el panorama regional y qué están
haciendo las entidades sanitarias de la
región para frenar este avance
marina uno de los principales retos que
tenemos con nuestra vive la química es
primero no compararla con kobe y segundo
hacer una pedagogía distinta qué
características tiene esta enfermedad 1
que es contagiosa por el contacto 2 que
el contacto y la habilidad respiratoria
puede transmitir la enfermedad hasta
tres semanas es decir veintiún días es
un periodo bastante prolongado y además
de eso que esta enfermedad se relaciona
mucho con la oportunidad de consultar lo
que estamos viendo en américa latina es
que las personas recurren a las
droguerías o no consultan por
desconocimiento de la enfermedad y son
eventualmente más transmisores durante
este tiempo que no tienen aislamiento y
contacto con los médicos para orientar
sus sobre sus tratamientos doctor muy
buen día en brasil también algunos
simios fueron envenenados con la
creencia que ellos transmitían este
virus recordemos entonces cómo se
produce actualmente la transmisión de
este brote y cuáles son las poblaciones
de mayor riesgo doctor
kabul eso refuerza mucho de la falta de
pedagogía hacer que la enfermedad
digamos algo así que los monos también
son afectados por este virus pero no
transmiten este virus este virus se
transmite es por roedores es una
zoonosis es decir que va del mundo
animal al mundo humano y este es el mono
como el humano son digamos unos
accidentales huéspedes de este virus
este luz no se transmite por tener monos
o por estar en contacto con ellos si no
es con personas que tengan lesiones en
la piel y que estas lesiones son las que
tienen esas burbujas llenas de virus que
pueden contagiar a otras personas no
tiene nada que ver aunque no se ve
aunque se recomienda que las personas
que están infectadas no manipulen
mascotas porque se puede hacer un
fenómeno reverso de que los humanos
infectan a otros animales y crear
reservorios pero no tienen nada que ver
los monos con la transmisión de la
enfermedad
doctor en en norteamérica canadá a
estados unidos y que están inoculando a
su población con la población de riesgo
con esta vacuna guineos sin embargo en
américa latina en la región
latinoamericana todavía ha desarrollado
una vacuna ni se están aplicando la
vacuna existente porque se debe esto y
que si denota una inequidad a la hora de
la adquisición de las vacunas en un modo
global
esta es una vacuna reciente ésta es una
vacuna que es más compleja porque es una
una de virus vivos no replicantes y es
una que tiene una limitación en la
producción porque digamos no se ha
prestado la atención hace muchos años de
esta enfermedad de esta vacuna ya está
desarrollada y hasta ahora es que se
están ampliando las cadenas de
producción fabricar vacunas no es un
proceso fácil ni sencillo requiere una
gran demanda tecnológica y por eso es
que se está haciendo incrementando la
capacidad de producción para poder
suplir las necesidades en el mundo es
este es un reto primero afortunadamente
hay vacuna que ya está desarrollada
antes de la pandemia distinto a lo que
pasó con joven que tuvimos que
desarrollar la altura de la pandemia sin
embargo las limitaciones para la
producción pues son la gran limitante
hoy para que no se ofrezcan todos los
países doctor y también en eeuu hay
algunos estudios que resaltan estas
desigualdades a la hora de acceder a la
vacuna por ejemplo las poblaciones
hispanas o afro son las que tienen
mayores números de contagio y sin
embargo son las que no se están
inoculando a qué se debe esto y si esto
que ya lo vimos también de la pandemia
de kobe 19 estas grandes inequidades y
desigualdades pues cómo puede afectar
ahora este brote de la viruela química
si lo que hemos visto durante todas
estas pandemias es que la inequidad
social se matiza mucho más fuerte o es
mucho más evidente en las situaciones
críticas creo que con esto de la
vacunación hay que ser también prudentes
porque digamos está también
caracterizando una orientación sexual
como un grupo de riesgo y si bien están
mayormente afectadas poblaciones gay no
quieres que todos no seamos susceptibles
lo segundo es que la vacunación
inicialmente hay que hacerse sobre los
contactos cercanos y lo tercero es que
también la pedagogía porque las personas
tenemos dificultad en que se refuercen
decoin exigimos una vacuna pero cuando
está disponible las personas no se
acercan y en eeuu también hay reportes
de que a pesar de ofrecer la vacuna hay
muchas poblaciones que no han querido
vacunarse esperando otra solución creo
que es un problema de energía económica
pero también inequidad educativa y
nosotros debemos fortalecer la pedagogía
sobre la enfermedad sobre la disponía de
la vacuna pero la mejor vacuna es
prevenir consultar al médico a si se
tiene dudas sobre el diagnóstico era un
profesional de la salud y no a un
dependiente de farmacia y siempre
guiarnos por las políticas nacionales y
las autoridades de cada uno de nuestros
países doctor como siempre muchísimas
gracias por estar con nosotros en
nuestro espacio de salud de france 24 el
doctor carlos eduardo pérez médico
infectólogo universidad nacional de
colombia asesor científico de france 24
gracias como siempre autor gracias
marina pasamos a saludar en nuestra
segunda invitada el día